hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in sermon number eight joseph butler is
going to distinguish between two
different kinds of anger one of which he
calls hasty or
sudden anger which is more instinctual
responding to
the perception of threat or injury or
inconvenience or opposition and then the
other which he calls
alternately resentment
or
deliberate or settled anger and this is
what we typically mean
by anger when we're thinking of it
and he tells us
that it is
naturally excited by
or intended to
prevent harm with something really
important the appearance
of wrong
or injustice so we we experience this
settled or deliberate anger
when we think that something is being
done that
violates some sort of norm something is
being done that's wrong something is
happening because another person has a
bad
motivation for what they're doing and as
he's going to tell us it's for the
administration of justice
but it's not just justice in a narrow
sense it's justice in the very broad
sense it's concerned with as he tells us
virtue and vice
moral good
and evil so we get angry at people when
we think that they are
vicious or
wicked or
exhibiting ill will or malice towards
ourself or to
other people
and he engages in a very interesting
thought experiment he says consider the
following so imagine first of all then
we're going to change some of the
parameters of what we're imagining so
imagine
first of all that your
reading or we could say in our own time
watching a show about or hearing
somebody talk about
some story
about basedness and villainy he says
that this is a feigned story so it's
made up right and it's feigned
specifically to arouse our passion of
anger now basedness means
being low being a bad person right and
villainy of course we know what a
villain is they're they're the bad guy
in in a show you know we just finished
watching
some of the cobra kai tv show
and you know you know who the bad guys
are because
you can tell
they wear the dark uniforms and they say
and do bad things and you know they're
the words are dripping with malice it's
very over the top right and we can think
about so many other framing techniques
so imagine a story like that right you
you get angry as he
says um
let us reflect upon the manner in which
we are touched when that happens he says
this immediately raises indignation
somewhat of a desire
that the villainy or baseness
should be punished that's what anger in
this sense settled or deliberate anger
is about and he says though the designed
injury be prevented yet though it was
designed is sufficient to raise this
inward feeling so the bad guy tries to
do something to the good guy and the
good guy
fends it off or something like that and
we're like oh i still don't like that
bad guy right they try to steal some
money and they it doesn't work they
still did a bad thing
and then he says all right
now
imagine the story true
does that change anything for us
and he goes on and he says
suppose the story true this inward
feeling would be as natural
and as just
and as one may venture to affirm their
scarcity man in the world but would have
it upon some occasions so
you know made up stories okay we can go
one way or the other we do get angry at
those if we actually suppose that it's a
true story now we get really angry i
can't believe they did that or i'm mad
at them right
and then he says
suppose that we know
the people involved in the story so we
know the
doer and we know the person things are
being done too
the fact that we know the doer means
that we also know that they are in fact
engaging in baseness and ability so we
know that they're a bad person
a bully for example right or a cheat or
pick whatever else you you want and we
know the victim of their
bad behavior
so he says neither would this make any
alteration only
that it would probably affect us more
meaning we get more angry
when we know the bad person person we
suppose is bad who's doing the bad
action or when we know the victim who is
being affected he says the indignation
raised by cruelty and injustice and the
desire of having it punished which
person's unconcerned would feel is by no
means malice it's resentment against
vice and wickedness you know this this
is part of what holds society together
he says uh each individual has it in
behalf of the whole
species and then he says all right let's
let's raise the bar a little bit more
suppose now the injury i've been
speaking of to be done against ourselves
or those whom we consider as ourselves
like our friends our family you know
depending on how we extend our what we
can call circles of concern maybe our
co-workers or
country uh
people right our neighbors and he says
it is plain in the way that we should be
affected would be exactly the same in
kind
but it would be in a higher degree
and
less transient so two different factors
there higher degree sort of like when we
know people we get madder well if it's
against ourselves or those who we
consider as ourselves we get even madder
right
less transient what does that mean less
likely to go away
taking longer to
dissipate perhaps we
hold grudges and why is this he says
because a sense of our own happiness and
misery is most intimately and always
present to us and from the very
constitution of our nature we cannot but
help have a greater sensibility to and
be more direct deeply interested in what
concerns our self so the fact that you
know it does affect us makes us
more liable to
greater anger he goes on and he talks
about
ways in which aggravating or lessening
the fault
heightens or lessens the resentment and
anger and before we look at the
the different uh
kinds
let's actually
reflect on something else that he
he talks about he says that
you know a lot of this has to do with a
sense of proportion right
so
we can sort of measure out the
likelihood
in a rough sense of the anger that's
going to be created so he talks about
for example
friendship and former obligations how
would that affect things now interesting
he doesn't actually
say
precisely how it will and we could say
well we're friends with somebody so
we're going to get less angry at them
because you know we already trust them
and we're more willing to give them the
benefit of the doubt
yes that could be true although we could
also
view it as a greater fault for a friend
to do something against us like for
example
to betray us in
financial matters
or in keeping our secrets or
in say sleeping with our uh significant
other or pick whatever you want right a
friend we could actually get angrier at
he talks about former obligations what
does he mean by that people that we had
connections to and perhaps have
discharged well maybe that lessens it or
maybe it increases it and then he talks
about something else that that could
lessen it right lessen the fault and
therefore lessen the resentment
inadvertency so inadvertency um means
that
you weren't trying to do that sort of
thing it just kind of happened that way
strong temptations you know do you get
as angry at a person
who you know is likely to fail
because of their temptations compared to
somebody else who
doesn't suffer from those temptations
now it's interesting because depending
on how we look at that person we might
be like you scumbag you gave in to your
addiction we get angry at them right
butler would actually say no we should
get angry at the person who doesn't have
a strong temptation and then finally
mistakes you know people make mistakes
they commit errors
uh they there's missed chances right if
we know that the person didn't intend to
do anything maybe we're not as
bothered by it
he also talks about carelessness now
carelessness you would think
should get somebody off the hook oh i
didn't mean to do it
except that butler says the reason we
get angry at carelessness
is because we ex we expect
observance being attentive
as a do so carelessness itself
is considered as faulty let's say
somebody's cutting your hair right
they're not a very conscientious you
know attentive person and they they cut
your hair too much and they're like oops
and you're like oops what and you're
like well
you know you're like let me take a look
at it you look at it and your hair is
all messed up and you're like we're
gonna have to shave the whole damn thing
off right now you're mad at them
they are supposed to be paying attention
to what they're doing right somebody
gives you change they should be actually
counting the money and we could go on
and on and on so you know carelessness
can be something that creates anger in
part because we feel like people owe it
to us
to pay attention to what they're doing
he also talks about another thing i'm
not quite sure whether we
all buy this or not he says that people
resent more strongly an injury done
than one which though designed was
prevented in cases where the guilt is
perhaps the same and his his reasoning
here is
that it is not the bear pain or loss
raises resentment but it gives a new and
as i may speak additional sense of the
injury or injustice so we already like
we perceive the bad intent of the person
and then they actually do something and
we're like oh you know greater than just
bad intent
i don't know i think a lot of people bad
intent is enough to make us
quite angry
and we're not as concerned whether they
actually were successful or not but
perhaps he's he's actually
right about that so
as you can see there's a lot of factors
going into determining
how this settled or deliberate anger
arises the intensity with which we feel
it
and you know how far we're willing to go
in our actions
butler i do want to emphasize as we
finish this up does think that there is
a good reason why we have this implanted
in our nature even though it makes us
you know go against benevolence or
compassion towards other people and that
is that it does in fact
help us to
prevent or remedy
injustice or vice or
moral evil so that is what
this settled or deliberate anger
is in us for
you